november 20 21 das virus ist mit aller
macht zurück die zahl der neuinfektionen
so hoch wie nie es greift unsere
gesundheit an und auch unsere
gemeinschaft passen bis zu gut hast du
dich nicht und zu lassen bis du böse
mehr als 56 millionen menschen sind
inzwischen vollständig geimpft aber es
gibt auch die anderen 20 prozent der
deutschen sagen nein zur corona in
deswegen aber nicht auf alles verzichten
der ton im land wird rauer die
bedrohungen massiver wenn man
gesundheitliche fürsorge leisten will
und das geht nur unter polizeischutz das
ist schon eine schöne sache die debatte
immer emotionaler stimmung ist absolut
vergiftet es gibt da der brüche geht
quer durch die gesellschaft gehen also
das wird immer härter der standpunkt des
einzelnen und das kann nicht der
richtige weg sei
zdfzoom wir wissen warum wird auch jetzt
noch übers impfen so heftig gestritten
[Musik]
rosenheim corona hotspot die zahl der
neuinfektionen so hoch wie nie alle
intensivstationen in der region sind
voll es gilt wieder der katastrophenfall
und seit gestern in bayern weitgehend
die zweijährige
am 20 oktober war das noch ganz anders
in cannes verein tanzen sie ist
seilschaft zwei dutzend kursteilnehmer
schieben sich über die tanzfläche feilen
an ihrer technik
was uns vereint ist die freude an der
gefühlten normalität die aus dem sommer
herr überreicht ob geimpft oder nicht
macht hier im moment keinen unterschied
ich bin genau
und der tanz trotzdem zusammen
darf ich fragen warum keine impfung
freilich noch nicht überzeugt
niemand auf der tanzfläche hat bedenken
denn der verein hat ein corona konzept
wer nicht geimpft ist muss getestet sein
beides wird am eingang kontrolliert
für die ungeimpften haben sie hier
selbsttests parat vor ort zu machen mit
jemandem der zuschaut ein test konzept
das für das training im tanzverein ende
oktober noch funktioniert wenn wir es
jetzt nicht mehr möglich wäre da muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen dann hätte ich
schon probleme prinzipielles problem
ja wenn wir das jetzt über den selbst
testen immer machen könnte und man
müsste
keine ahnung mit anderen testungen
daherkommen das ist ein punkt des
workshop ist wie ton hört weil man
akzeptieren das ist ob dieses verein
frank bauer ist ungeimpft der
selbstständige handwerker hat viel zeit
in dieses hobby investiert hat den
tanzboden eingebaut spenden organisiert
ist wichtiger motor des vereins
wer diese zwei agiere regel wenn es denn
so wäre oder 3g plus das war absolutes
ausschlusskriterium
also da würde prinzipiell nicht mit
kindern mit sobald die inzidenz die
kritische marke übersteigt und die
maßnahmen verschärft werden musste für
einen pcr tests von den ungeimpften
verlangen
drei wochen nach diesem abend ist es
soweit
anfang november wir treffen frank bauer
auf dem berg er geht nicht mehr tanzen
und hat sich auch aus der vereinsarbeit
zurückgezogen ihm bleibt nicht mehr viel
was er als ungeimpfte unternehmen kann
warum ist er trotzdem gegen die impfung
zwar nicht von anfang an aber mit
meiner meinung nach einer reihe von
fragwürdigen politischen erlassenen
verordnungen trotz des immer mehr
verfestigt und jetzt ist eigentlich der
pieks dann immer so das thema sondern
einfach ich will einen teil dieses
systems drin es kann nicht sein dass
repression und ausgrenzung dass das
richtig er habe sein vertrauen in die
politik verloren sagt frank bauer im
zweiten lockdown vor einem jahr als man
in bayern noch nicht einmal alleine auf
den berg gehen durfte
die rekord ins identen machen ihm keine
sorgen aber die vergiftete stimmung wie
er es nennt
neu ist auch hier oben am berg stößt er
ohne impfung an grenzen
warum aber streiten wir darüber so
heftig frank bauer meint nachdem die
bedenken des fußballers user kimmig
gegen die impfung öffentlich wurden sei
es für ungeimpfte wie ihn noch
schwieriger geworden
eine stimme kriegen können
im alpenvorland spitzt sich die lage zu
die anzahl der kogit patienten steigt
dramatisch die krankenhaus april steht
in ganz bayern auf rot die kritische
marke auf den intensivstationen ist seit
mehr als einer woche überschritten auch
hier im romed klinikum ist man am ende
seiner kapazität karl ziegler ist hier
oberarzt es ist ein eintauchen in eine
andere welt mit strengsten
sicherheitsmaßnahmen
seit beginn der panini berichte ich über
das virus und dessen folgen aus vielen
intensivstationen über das leid die
anstrengung den kampf ums überleben der
gewonnen aber auch verloren wird
die impfung der weg aus der pandemie
doch nicht alle wollen diesen gehen der
ausnahmezustand ist hier die regel seit
fast zwei jahren und das leben draußen
ist weit weg
signale aus den überwachungsgeräten
bestimmen den takt
der tun ist ein anderer hier
wir betreuen patienten in allen
altersklassen zwischen ganz jungen und
fortgeschritten zum ganz ganz ganz
überwiegenden teil um geimpft ist
natürlich nicht schön dieser patient ist
anfang 50 bis vor wenigen tagen war er
kerngesund bis er sich mit dem virus
infizierte er ist einer von acht schwer
kranken die aktuell in der klinik
behandelt werden alle sind umgehend in
der zeit von mitte oktober bis anfang
november waren bundesweit unter den 18
bis 59 jährigen polit intensivpatienten
13 prozent geimpft 87% umkämpft
katharina lena ist chefärztin der
station einem jungen kit patienten geht
es schlecht letzten 24 stunden waren
sukzessiven verschlechterungen des
gesamtzustandes
angehörigen sprechen
immer häufiger müssen sie kurvig
patienten mit schweren
krankheitsverläufen ablehnen weil dies
personell einfach nicht mehr schiffe
ende september waren wir schon einmal
hier auch damals waren alle
intensivbetten mit ungeimpften
schwerkranken belegt wie diese patientin
die nicht zu erkennen sein wollte
es muss wirklich ganz schlimm um mich
gestanden haben dass überlegt wurde ob
man nicht ins künstliche koma liegt es
muss sehr kritisch gewesen sein
auch sie hatte sich nicht impfen lassen
weil ich dem impfstoff nicht vertrauen
alles ging viel zu schnell es gibt keine
langzeitstudien und obwohl ich hier seit
über einer woche liege hat sich an
meiner meinung nichts geändert ich würde
mich nach wie vor nicht impfen lassen
das verständnis weil wir nur mit mühe
und not geschafft haben diese frau an
der künstlichen beatmung vorbei zu
schiffen mit viel liebe und viel
zuwendung und das
kann man schwer verstehen
ein mensch verweigert die impfung obwohl
er die gefährlichkeit des virus selbst
erfahren hat ein einzelfall nein sagen
die mediziner hier eher die rede
einen monat später ende oktober ist die
stimmung im team spürbar angespannt das
virus ist der mit aller macht und trifft
auf ein geschwächtes gesundheitssystem
mit zunehmend erschöpften und
ernüchterten mitarbeitern die arbeit mit
ungeimpften belastet mittlerweile viele
hier manche haben aufgegeben denn sie
sehen kein ende der krise
nie aus der pandemie herauskommen und
wir werden unsere freiheiten nie wieder
gelangen so lange die leute nicht mehr
sagt eine die um das leben vieler
ungeimpfter kämpft manches mal auch
hitlers
wie viele menschen nach einer cupid
infektion sterben ist auch eine frage
der impfquote das zeigt der blick in
andere länder was sind die hauptgründe
für die impfskepsis laut einer aktuellen
umfrage halten 74 prozent der
ungeimpften die korona vakzine für zu
wenig erprobt finden 67 prozent den
druck von aussen zu groß haben 62
prozent angst vor impfschäden und
langzeitfolgen
bei unserer recherche spüren wir welche
gräben sich auftun zwischen geimpften
und ungeimpften unter welchem druck
unsere gesprächspartner stehen viele
reden mit uns aber kaum einer will das
auch vor der kamera tun beide seiten
fürchten ausgrenzung anfeindungen
negative folgen am arbeitsplatz wir sind
in sachsen im bundesland mit der
höchsten sieben tage instanz und der
niedrigsten impfquote in
görlitz treffen sich die impfgegner auf
der straße sie pochen auf ihr recht sich
nicht impfen zu lassen jeden montagabend
ziehen die korona skeptiker durch die
innenstadt
sie sind laut sie sind präsent manche
radikalisiert
die geimpften sind auch in sachsen in
der mehrheit aber die impfgegner
scheinen den ton anzugeben anna elisa
lorkowski organisiert die
montagsspaziergänge mit auch sie ist
nicht geimpft
es ist fast schon normal in görlitz
menschen ohne maske anzutreffen wie in
diesem bioladen
hier treffen wir ruiner elisa lorkowski
wieder sie ist mutter von drei kindern
und lehrerin an der waldorfschule es hat
sich über die wochen so ein bisschen
sortiert wer
keine maske tragen kann und da
unbehelligt einkaufen gehen will der
kommt an tieren und
wem das aber nicht geheuer ist der geht
halt woanders hin die 40 jährige glaubt
dass impfungen schädlich sind und trägt
keine maske weil sie darunter schlecht
luft bekommen dafür habe sie ein attest
von ihrem hausarzt
ich bin total glücklich über diese kurze
normalität die ich hier habe wenn ich
jetzt nicht roh korrigiert oder im
baumarkt was pocher dann ist das anders
dann ist das für mich immer schwierig
weil ich
bin mir sicherlich auch ein aber so
diese klinischen clicker da ist eine
ohne maske
ist anstrengend
seit zwei jahren des lorkowski in
elternzeit
du hast zwei kinder einer davon es elf
ja wenn du möchtest nicht dass der in
die schule genau
ich habe gemerkt diese diese denkweise
es gibt da eine unsichtbare bedrohung
und für ein kind ist das unsichtbar das
kann sich überhaupt nichts unter während
vorstellen wie soll man da ein sicheres
lebensgefühl entwickeln wenn man sich
selbst als eine gefahr sieht die
unsichtbaren leute die das auch
kritisieren das sagen
ganz viel um verständnis für meine
mutter ist es ein problem die isseler
die ist lehrerin und die ist vollblut
überzeugte staatsschule lehrerin
und gesagt wie kannst du nur kannst das
kind hat keine zukunft das du kannst das
antun
der umgang der politik mit der korona
pandemie schwer durchschaubare
regelungen und fragwürdige machten deals
haben lorkowski noch misstrauischer
gemacht gegenüber staatlichen
institutionen
es gibt sehr viele missstände
korruption catella
machenschaften
das wird jetzt zeit dass wir die
dass wir uns davon trennen dass wir sie
überwinden das ist aufklären dass die
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden
nein sagen zur impfung als du viele auch
nein sagen zum start
[Musik]
seit jahren beschäftigt sich der
soziologe armin nassehi mit dem
auseinanderdriften der gesellschaft das
thema impfen zeige da eine besondere
sprengkraft
wenn ich versuche jemandem zu erklären
warum die impfung eigentlich wie heißt
es so schön alternativlos ist dann ist
es für den natürlich ein beweis dafür
dass die eliten des staates und der
wissenschaft und derer die in den medien
reden und so weiter unglaublich viele
argumente aufbringen um ihnen die
unwahrheit zu erzählen dagegen kommen
sie mit argumenten tatsächlich schwer an
und das macht die situation auch so
kompliziert sind wir da am ende der
diskussion angelangt weil es tatsächlich
keinen ausweg gibt wahrscheinlich wird
der ausweg daran liegen dass man
impfungen vor diesem sinn überschuss
befreit also wenn wir in den nächsten
jahren
routinen einsetzen können in denen die
impfung gegen kuwait 19 eine ähnliche
impfung ist wie andere impfungen auch
dann wird womöglich die impfrate steigen
bremen das bundesland mit der höchsten
impfquote in deutschland über 81 prozent
und mit einer sieben tage incidents von
113 ungeimpfte sind hier ganz klar in
der minderheit
andreas löffel ist in skeptiker
politisch aktiv in der partei die basis
sie gilt als partei politische arm der
querdenker bewegung mit querdenkern
arbeite dafür habe er nichts am hut den
finanzen ein er vertrat auf die eigenen
abwehrkräfte
ich bin etwas über 50 aber sportlich fit
deswegen glaube ich dass ich keine
infektion mit einem milden verlauf gut
überstehen würden wenn sie hat die
intensivsitzung schauen sind jetzt in
erster linie ungeimpfte aufstellung
nein überhaupt nicht
die art und weise wie dort gezielt wird
gibt es glaube ich kaum jemandem bekannt
die tatsache dass führende politiker mit
dieser pandemie der ungeimpften und der
speziell der jüngeren um die jetzt
posieren gehen wenn ich das so sagen
darf
dann ist das in meinen augen ein klein
wenig panikmache tatsache ist dass die
inzidenz bei ungeimpften bis zu 20 mal
höher als bei geimpften sind zwischen
februar und november sind in deutschland
1399 kubik patienten unter 60 gestorben
25 mal geimpft 1,8
viele in seinem umfeld haben sich impfen
lassen auch seine 82-jährige mutter
stress gebe es da keinen nur wenn er
ausgeht stoße er an grenzen in bremen
sind die korona regeln überall präsent
und selbstverständlich nicht für löffel
er fühlt sich zunehmend ausgeschlossen
vom sozialen leben das maß der
ausgrenzung gegen jauch immer schärferer
form an man weiß ja auch gar nicht mehr
wo das hingehen soll
einige politiker und funktionäre
überbieten sich ja geradezu im zwang zu
2g das macht für mich die ausgrenzung
für ihn ausgrenzung für andere
lebensnotwendige
schutzmaßnahmen in bremen wird schon
lange über 2g nachgedacht das heißt zu
treten nur noch für geimpfte und
genesene bei fußball club werder bremen
ist das schon die regel ungeimpfte wie
er müssen draußen bleiben nicht mehr der
mensch zählt weil man nur noch als
ärgernis als gesundheitsgefahr
wahrgenommen wird reduziert und die
menschlichkeit bleibt komplett auf der
strecke vielleicht wird er sich impfen
lassen aber wann und womit das sei seine
privatsache hier die entscheidung des
einzelnen dort der schutz der
gesellschaft noch ist impfen das beste
mittel im kampf gegen korona das zeigt
auch der blick in andere länder zum
thema impfbereitschaft forscht
psychologin kathrin schmelzer
individuelle freiheit oder solidarität
in der impf debatte prallen diese werte
aufeinander da ist ein dilemma auf der
einen seite wollen wir dass möglichst
viele menschen geimpft sind auf der
anderen seite kann druck gegen druck aus
bewirken aber was macht das dann mit
einer gesellschaft es wird frust mit
sich bringen auf jeden fall auf beiden
seiten die einen fühlen sich unter druck
gesetzt und die anderen fühlen sich im
stich gelassen
es kann ja möglicherweise die
gesellschaft spalten
zurück nach bremen im stadtteil
gröpelingen leben vor allem menschen mit
migrationshintergrund lange war das
viertel ein corona hotspot die stadt
handelte und schickt der sozialarbeiter
wie bülent axa carl auf den plan statt
konfrontation aufklären und reden mit
den menschen
da versuche ich halt so ein mediator zu
sagen zwischen der politik zwischen der
wissenschaft auf der einen seite und auf
der seite der mensch der als sich nicht
impfen das wohl gesagt das ist mein
körper mir soll keiner ran und die mauer
zu durchbrechen und erstmal nicht daran
zu denken der mensch muss ich jetzt
unbedingt impfen lassen
streitberger zoff kommt vor rupert hier
jedoch nicht aus in der mehrheit reden
miteinander diskutieren 2000 sich aus
auch wenn es natürlich polarisierende
seinen gibt und auch die unter risse
durch gewisse familien gehen oder
gruppen
mittendrin ein großer supermarkt
wichtige anlaufstelle für die menschen
hier
touran elsbeck ist der besitzer 20
angestellte hatte impfen oder nicht
darüber wurde zunächst heftig gestritten
er vertraute dem gesundheitssystem wie
er sagt und ließ sich als einer der
ersten impfung ich fürchte diese
hingegen nicht sie müssen sich impfen
lassen weil es ist die krankheit die
behandelt werden das können wir nur wenn
wir uns alle an anstand ziehen
diese ganze inf debatte sagt bülent habe
auch etwas gutes die menschen setzen
sich intensiv damit auseinander dass im
tempo zieht auch hier wieder an das ist
auch bülent zuzuschreiben immer mehr
ungeimpfte kämen so bianca becker von
der impfstelle der drucker zu wachsen
ganz klar wenn man einlädt und man hat
eben von ungeimpften dabei dann weiß ich
halt nicht möchte ich dennoch neben dem
sitzen ist der raum groß genug
michael db kette lange gezögert sich
impfen zu lassen doch jetzt gibt er dem
druck aus seinem umfeld nach
schon im bekanntenkreis alles wm und
wenn man das diskutieren kommen wir das
gleich emotional hast du dich impfen
lassen bis du gut hast du dich nicht um
verlassen ist der böse
was ist gut was ist böse in der debatte
ist das umso mehr eine frage des
standpunkts in görlitz wurde in fast
hans christian gottschalk in sozialen
netzwerken aufs übelste beschimpft weil
es 72 jährige auch jugendliche impft
seinem kollegen henry hedrich ging es
ähnlich weil er im verweigerer in seiner
praxis nicht mehr behandeln wollte erst
nach längerem zögern haben sich die
beiden bereit erklärt mit uns zu reden
denn sie befürchten weitere anfeindungen
ein problem das die menschen auf zu
respektlos geworden sind und dass man
nicht fair meinungen austauschen sondern
dass man
einfach menschen mit den einstigen
gemein hat oft beleidigt und und
sozusagen verunglimpft
das hat der kinderarzt dr gottschalk am
eigenen leib erlebt als er vor einigen
wochen hier in diese berufsschule cham
um über zwölfjährige zu impfen wurde er
von radikalen impfgegnern empfangen und
bedrängt
mich haben sie halt als verbrecher
tituliert und
dass ich eigentlich vor ein
kriegsgericht gehören würde was ich hier
den kindern und jugendlichen antue und
dass sie schon wussten wer ich bin und
wo ich wohne und dass ich meinen der
gerechten strafe zugeführt
würde und meine tochter hat aber geweint
als sie das mitbekommen hat und hat
wirklich angst um nicht gehabt das
allererste mal ja und meine tochter self
hier halt und das hat mich schon sehr
bewegt haben wie man mit diesen leuten
geredet
mit solchen leuten
nein mit solchen leuten habe ich nicht
geredet ja weil ich habe mit vielen
menschen geredet die skepsis skeptisch
dem öffentlichen überstanden und wo es
auch einen sinn macht finden vernünftige
argumente auszutauschen aber mit denke
dass diese menschen nicht zugänglich
sind einem normalen gespräch die
infektion musste von der polizei
geschützt werden
impfgegner führen diese angriffe auch
aus den sozialen medien heraus es ist
nur eine kleine gruppe jedoch sie
hinterlässt spuren
das hat mir das vor beginn durchaus
verunsichert
und auch in frage gestellt ist das
impfen richtig und das ist eine völlig
groteske situation haben sich gefragt
bin ich auf dem richtigen weg bin ich
echt noch auf der richtigen seite und
natürlich nach kurzem nachdenken
natürlich muss ich muss meine pflicht
als hausarzt wahrnehmen ich muss das
impfen hoch halten dass der einzige
möglichkeit aus dieser pandemie
herauszufinden es ist eine nebenwirkung
der impfung der ton ist schärfer
geworden oft schrill voller
ausrufezeichen kleine gruppen nutzen
auch die sozialen medien um sich gehör
zu verschaffen
nach beobachtungen des soziologen armin
nassehi wird das ganz bewusst eingesetzt
je lauter waren ist unsere stärker wird
man gehört weil die leute die so verroht
sprechen in der öffentlichen debatte
stärker vorkommen als ihr anteil an der
bevölkerung oder an der öffentlichen
diskussion ist das sind eigentlich die
üblichen mechanismen die wir bei solchen
führungen kennen warum muss sich auch
lohnen und nur dann nur dann wird sie
auch angewandt
auch an schulen tun sich gräben auf als
vor den herbstferien positive fälle
auftauchten wurden die ungeimpften an
diesem görlitzer gymnasium nach hause
geschickt die halbe oberstufe für zwei
tage das fangen sie ungerecht und
forderten es müssten alle geimpft oder
nicht in den distanz unterricht
ich habe es total mies gefunden erst mal
bei zeit eine situation ist wo man immer
dachte sowas wird niemals die eintreten
danach wird niemals die durch sortiert
zum ersten mal fühlte sich die 18
jährige julien ausgeschlossen vor die
tür gesetzt die geimpfte viktor hingegen
fand ist nur konsequent wir alle kannten
diesen vorteil und einige haben sich
halt deswegen verlassen und andere nicht
und die geimpften haben dann halt den
nutzen daraus gezogen dass sie weiterhin
im präsenzunterricht in
kleinen stellen sich hier
grundsatzfragen was ist gerecht wäre es
der maßstab sind es die ungeimpften oder
die geimpften jeder reklamiert das für
sich also vereinigen an dem tag war eine
riesen diskussion in auf whatsapp in
unseren schätzt man muss sich doch nur
im verlassen es ist doch nicht viel es
ist auch nur eine kleine impfe und dann
kannst du auch wieder zur schule gehen
also das war halt so momente wo auch ich
dachte das ist total unnötig ist weiter
zu diskutieren
geimpft oder nicht das ist unter den
schülern aber keine frage die über
freundschaften entscheidet und was
schnell hochgekocht war kam auch schnell
wieder runter
ich denke auch dass
die situation gezeigt hat dass zwischen
den schülern auch wenn man sich
vielleicht nicht gut kennt also nicht
nur innerhalb der freundesgruppen
sondern auch so ein bisschen
übergreifender da der zusammenhalt
einfach besteht also an sich hat er
einfach nur gezeigt dass wir
unterschiedliche meinungen vertreten
aber wir auch damit klar also trotzdem
noch miteinander klarkommen können dass
wir trotzdem noch so viel verständnis
auf
mit rasant steigenden zahlen werden
verschärfte coroner regeln eingeführt
wie zweig in sachsen und bayern oder es
wird darüber nachgedacht auch im
berufsleben
eine großbaustelle im norden von bremen
und 100 mitarbeiter beschäftigt
bauunternehmer jan gerd pröger geimpften
und ungeimpften jeden tag stellt sich
hier die frage wen müssen wir vor wem
schützen müssen wir die
dümmsten vor den nicht geimpften
schützen oder umgekehrt
gerade erst musste ein geimpfter
mitarbeiter als kontaktperson in
quarantäne
nach drei tagen kann man wieder zur
arbeit wurde im hintergrund dass alle
wussten dass er positiv getestet das
kind zu hause hat war natürlich dann
gerade bei den ungeimpften große
aufregung sie hatten angst dass der
geimpfte das virus überträgt in solchen
situationen hilft nur eines so polier
gunnar humburg reden reden reden und die
beiden gruppen voneinander trennen
sie schrieben sich die
fahrgemeinschaften auseinander so soll
aufwand kennen sie das denn verstehen
das leben menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen
ich habe zurückzustehen
statt hand den hansa hamburg mache jeder
sein ding und fertig und dennoch man
darf die aber auch nicht außer
gesellschaft ausschließen ich muss die
gelegenheit haben wenn ich mich frei
teste ich
getestet bin dass ich ganz normal an der
gesellschaft teilnehmen kann für den
bauunternehmer ist dies keine option
denn immer häufiger stellen sich seine
auftraggeber quer wollen keine
ungeimpften auf dem bau die konsequenz
spätestens wenn der rohbau fertig und
die fenster drin sind gilt hier die 2g
regel noch genießen oder geimpft
im schlimmsten fall kann ihnen der
verlust ihres arbeitsplatzes drohen
harte konsequenzen die angesichts der
steigenden inzidenz in vielen bereichen
diskutiert werden überall hinterlässt
der streit ums impfen seine spuren
gräben werden aufgerissen tiefe risse
entstehen das hat folgen für unser
zusammenleben stellt psychologin katrin
schmelz fest wir müssen akzeptieren dass
die pandemie unsere gesellschaft
durchgerüttelt und teilweise neu
geordnet hat weil so grund haltende
auffassungen aufeinander geprallt sind
zwischen menschen die vorher ganz eng
beieinander waren aber wenn da in
familien in paaren unter freundschaften
unterschiedliche positionen waren
hat das teilweise auch beziehungen
zerschlagen und auf der anderen seite
beziehungen neu geordnet warum streiten
wir auch jetzt noch so heftig über das
impfen weil es dabei ums eingemachte
geht um unser bild von der welt und von
uns selbst weil es darum geht wie ich
verantwortung definieren und solidarität
wovor ich angst habe und wie ich mich
verhalte im angesicht einer wachsenden
gefahr die tödlich sein kann und viele
opfer gefordert hat mit allen
konsequenzen für unsere gesellschaft